I don't want to talk a lot about this
but I think it makes sense to say
something about it a few days ago Donald
Trump and people around him have
switched to calling the coronavirus the
Chinese virus and there was an immediate
reaction from a lot of people that's
racist
it's xenophobic so on and so forth and
it may well be but I want to give you my
take on where I am on this this cannot
be allowed to become a distraction from
the failed slow response from the Trump
administration and actually dealing with
the virus I don't even care to argue
about is Chinese virus racist or isn't
it well they called it the Spanish flu
well but the Spanish flu was really from
Kansas and/or France it wasn't actually
from Spain
that's a fine debate to have I guess
maybe but if we allow there's a limited
amount of time in the day there's a
limited amount of time that people are
paying attention to the news there's a
limited amount of time that people put
effort and time into answering the
question what do I need to do right now
to help rather than her with coronavirus
if we allow Trump to make the discussion
about Chinese virus we are taking time
away from the important stuff he gets to
control the narrative and in fact during
yesterday's coronavirus briefing press
conference that complete propaganda
network oann one american news network
that now has a seat in the White House
press briefing room this journalist in
the back asks some bizarre question
about is Chinese virus really racist if
it is then you then the term Chinese
food would also be racist and Trump
liked the question and so on and so
forth and was able to waste five minutes
talking about how unfairly the New York
Times treats him and CNN and all of this
other stuff just don't allow it it's
idiotic this Chinese virus stuff is
completely idiotic but the more we take
the bait on it the more the attention is
not on why aren't we testing why don't
we taste testing large asymptomatic
populations to figure out how many
people who have no symptoms are
potentially super spreaders of the
disease etc etc etc so I don't even want
to spend a lot of time here
think you know a couple a couple minutes
I just spent is enough the Chinese virus
stuff it's crazy but the more we feed
into it and talk about it the less we're
talking about the more important stuff
so we're going to try to stay away from
that topic we've got a full program for
you today make sure you're following me
on Twitter at Dee Pakman much more
coming right up